Today, we are learning English with The Lion King.
One of the most acclaimed Disney animations of all time.
If you want to keep learning with the best movies and tv series
so you can finally understand fast speaking natives
Without getting lost, without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles,
then click on the subscribe button and bell down below.
Like community member Nora who says that she is amazed
that thanks to our channel
now she can understand more than 70% of movies
when she watches them.
I hope you enjoyed learning with The Lion King today.
And if you can't get enough of lessons with your favorite tv series,
movies and songs, then make sure you follow us on Instagram because we make new lessons there every single day.
And if you're looking for another lesson to watch, why not check out our Disney playlist where we have a bunch of great lessons
you can continue learning with.